gary is with us in Wisconsin hey Gary
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show thanks
for taking my call Dave sure what's up
so me my wife were newly married we make
about $100,000 a year
and we have about seventy thousand
dollars in debt so my question is we
have one of our cars as $24,000 vo on it
the other one is 19,000 and then we also
have a motorcycle for 14,000 and student
loan debt of 14,000 what I'm wondering
is I'd like to attack the student loan
first but at the same time we're willing
to get rid of our cars the one that we
owe 24 on is worth probably about 19,000
and the one that we own
99 is probably worth about 15,000 would
it be better to get rid of those first
two three free up our payment of about a
thousand dollars a month and then go
after the student loan in the motorcycle
after that you didn't mention getting
rid of the motorcycle well I also get
rid of the motorcycle yeah absolutely
okay yep but I just didn't know because
the motorcycle payment is 200 and I
think $30 and what's a motorcycle
where's the car probably about 10 or 11
okay so they're all three upside down
somewhat correct yes sir okay I think
you take the big one and get rid of it
first and then get rid of the next one
and then get rid of the next one and
then you're gonna be down to the
unsecured loans you have associated with
having gotten rid of these cars and
getting you some hoop tees and and your
student loans so you're probably going
to end up with 20 $25,000 worth of debt
instead of 75 it says 70 when all the
smoke clears it sounds to me like
correct yep absolutely
and like I said I just wasn't sure which
one to attack first so but yeah how old
are you guys everything will be gone 28
okay that's how old I was when I went
broke and lost everything so I will tell
you what you're proposing is very
emotional too
dump all these vehicles because I'm
guessing you are a car guy
you're a vehicle guy yep your wife is
probably ambivalent to this yep so the
the good news about not only your
willingness to do this but to actually
do it is you will shock your spirit and
it will change shape and it will never
be the same I know that cuz I'm you
thirty years later okay
and so because I'm a car guy and if it
had a motor in it I would buy it if it
had wheels I would buy it that was me
and I still like cars and vehicles and
now I've got a bunch now that I'm
wealthy but but but the what happened
was my I don't know my spirit changed
shape to where now I own the vehicles
and they don't own me anymore I don't
get the little boy child excitement from
vehicles anymore it's just a car it's
cool car but it's just a car I drove a
raptor down here it's a cool truck but
it's just a truck and so if somebody
tears it up runs into it I don't go into
meltdown the freakout mode I don't lose
my mind because about the shape of my
spirit changed once I had to start over
at hoop deal and and work my way back
out and you don't have to because you're
going broke you have to because you're
choosing to but in addition to the
mathematical benefit of what you're
proposing what I'm saying is is it's
going to change the shape of your
personal spirit permanently and you'll
always enjoy vehicles because you're a
guy that does but you'll enjoy them in a
more mature richer way rather than a
less of a little boy kind of way at
least I did that's what happened to me
so hey thanks for the call man it's good
discussion